joining us now is harvard professor of
the practice of public philosophy
dr cornell west himself thank you so
much for coming on the show
thank you my dear brother for having me
and you've been doing a wonderful job
wonderful job we appreciate that
so i want to talk to you about biden's
appointments and his agenda but before i
get to that can i just double check
this year you didn't go third party did
you you voted for joe biden for the
democrat for president
part of an anti-fascist coalition a
coalition that said
we've got to get brother trump out he's
a neo-fascist gangster he calls him to
question the very possibilities of any
kind of democratic politics
looks like that coalition did come
together he's on the way out we hope
and now we've got to deal with the
neoliberal disaster of biden
and harris and we've got to be very
honest about i think
they're going to be much better in terms
of stability
but the rot is still there remember that
wonderful line in shakespeare's hamlet
something is rotten in the state of
denmark something's rotten in the united
states the creed
and the corruption and i think biden and
harris can
redirect the rock maybe slow down the
rock but the greed will still be there
the big money will still be there
the benefactors the donors will still be
there the mass incarceration system will
still be in place
the pentagon militarism will still be
expanded we've already seen that now in
the middle east africom and africa and
so forth so we got to just tell the
truth we've got to be committed brother
and you know as a journalist to the
truth and the condition of truth is to
allow suffering to speak yeah we got to
be committed to justice so
it's not a matter of identity you get
you got an all-women group women can lie
just like men black people can lie just
like white people like brown people
indigenous people so it's integrity i
want to come back to that
that's what we're concerned about i'm
going to jump in i'm going to jump in
i want to get into that with you you've
jumped ahead to my next question but
before we get to that
a great point you're making there before
we get into that important discussion
just to finish off this
point your critics would say yay well
done congratulations for being part of
an anti-fascist coalition in 2020
why weren't you part of that
anti-fascist coalition in 2016 do you
regret your vote in 2016 did you just
not realize how bad trump would be
i thought that maybe there would be
stronger mechanisms of accountability
for trump i really did and i didn't even
think that trump would act
win and when he when it so i thought
that by supporting clinton
that it was just a matter of trying to
generate a longer deeper left opposition
because i didn't think that
that trump was going to win i thought
hillary was going to win no matter what
and i'm in the state of massachusetts
you know that was going to go for sister
hillary no matter what
anyway very much so yeah okay now if
hillary
clinton talked about him this time i
would have supported her i would have
supported hillary this time
as much as i'm critical of her because
that's parker that's just coalition
fair enough no no i totally understand
where you're coming from in terms of
anti-fascism
let me ask you this let's talk about the
people biden is appointed you just
touched on an important issue
they're very qualified clearly very
clever especially compared to the
current bunch they're replacing
they're also very diverse for example
fox news is reporting
that biden might select former ci
veteran daryl blocker
as his new cia director he would be the
first black man to run the cia and he
would be working directly under the
first
woman to be director of national
intelligence avril haynes
in addition you've got the first
all-female white house communications
team as i just mentioned
the first female treasury secretary
janet yellen she's one of four women on
biden's top
economic team including a former
princeton colleague of yours
african-american economist cecilia rouse
who will run the council of economic
advisers now they're all undeniably
ground-breaking firsts
but some on the left say no it's
meaningless identity politics a
distraction from their views
from their ideology where do you stand
on this
well i would say it's not meaningless
it's significant to have
a variety of different kinds of people
on the inside but it's not their racial
or
gender or sexual orientation identity
that is the major marker i want to know
what kind of integrity they have
i want to know what kind of analysis and
vision they have i want to
know what kinds of concerns do they have
for poor people
yeah i'm part of the legacy of martin
king brother until the day i die
and poor people working people no matter
what color
not just here but around the world in
ethiopia in west bank in gaza
in tel aviv in guatemala this is a
spiritual and a moral matter that's why
when shakespeare talks about rottenness
he's saying that the corruption and the
greed
cuts much deeper than just identity
uh a a politics it's a human thing
and that's why predatory capitalism
that's why
militarism comes out of the pentagon
these are not pc categories
these are actual realities that are
crushing
precious human beings of all color
and if we lose the moral and spiritual
standards
in talking about identity then we're
going to end up with just a more
diverse empire a more diverse predatory
capitalism
a more diverse patriarchal orientation
because you know women can fit into
patriarchal identities
quickly in the same way black folks can
fit in the white supremacist one
so that i never say it's meaningless i
do want to see diversity
but i want to see diversity
i think that's very well put i mean
people forget donald trump appointed a
woman to run the cia
uh it does it doesn't mean that the cia
was suddenly a progressive institution
overnight
um let's talk about let's talk about
economics something
subject close to your heart the state of
the economy poverty inequality
the new york times had a headline today
uh we'll put it on screen
quote biden's economic picks suggest
focus on workers
and income equality there is good news
in there for progressives isn't there
people like
cecilia rouse who i mentioned and jared
bernstein they have strong progressive
economic records
i i think i mean cecilia ross is my dear
sister as you know she's the uh
daughter-in-law of the one and only tony
morris you know the greatest
literary artist of our day i have great
respect for her mind but keep in mind
she was part of the same
lauren summer dominated council
under obama now i don't know exactly
where her voice was but
she strikes me still as very much in a
neo-liberal zone she could be changing i
know recently she's talked about a call
for
serious relief so you got i want to give
people a chance
but but i like that that that verb
suggests
because we got to see what kind of
priorities
are they really going to have janet
yellen yelling and trained by
joseph stieglitz joseph piglets is one
of the most important of progressive
economists around
will she be able to deal with that
stigler's james tobin legacy she got
from yale
or will she fit right into the bin neo
liberal project
we don't know we shall see with our dear
sister
yeah i want to give a chance but i'm i'm
going to be sure
not in a personal way but in a
principled moral spiritual and political
way because
the right degree the indifference toward
the suffering of foreign working people
of all colors in america
can keep alive the fascist movement
that's what keeps the lives of trump is
but not just trump himself
but so many of the folks they're looking
for
some alternative to the inequality and
here comes trump
pie piper in his own way supervising
also there's this issue where i i worry
that the bar is so low anyone who's not
trump
or not mnuchin or not ben carson is
suddenly amazing i think we need to
raise the bar on what we expect
from our officials let me and on that
note let you let me ask you
about the most controversial name
floated so far
about a day ago it was rumored that rahm
emanuel might be the next transportation
secretary
but as the mayor of chicago of course
he's been accused of covering up
key elements in the investigation into
the police killing of laquan mcdonald a
black teenager
only releasing a damning video of the
shooting after a court ordered it
how bothered would you be by the
appointment of rahm emanuel to biden's
cabinet
well brother rahm i've been full of his
for decades
not only because of his uh uh cover-up
of brother laquan but again his
neoliberal politics i mean we we know
from brother barack obama's
a new book or promised land where it
ends up brother barack
it's through the promised land it
doesn't take a whole lot of folk with
him as it were
but it's clear that it was romney mania
who was pushing
the centrist neo-liberal policies that
would not speak
to the depths of the crisis in
catastrophe on wall street
and allowed for the wall street gangster
to get all free
the wall street criminals to get off
free and then
the policy of general providing the
trillions of dollars
to those wall street folks the very
criminals who had caused the crisis
benefit so that's not just a matter of
race here we're talking about economic
injustice tied to brother rum and he's
got to be he got to take responsibility
for that so yes i'd be
very upset but it's not just wrong it's
just there's a whole
array of those moderate neoliberals who
constitute the corporate wing of the
democratic party that was not fair to my
brother bernie sanders but i know that's
over now
but we have got to be vigilant
individually in our voices
and collectively on the street fighting
in harris
we shall see it's suggesting that you're
going to deal with
some inequality in poverty let us see
and execute
i want to come back to you and bernie
sanders in a moment but just sticking
with the biden team most of these names
these appointees
are veterans of the obama administration
which i know you had
high hopes for you campaigned for back
in 2007 2008
you supported barack obama's campaign
you said you hoped he would be a
black lincoln by 2011 uh you had called
him quote a black mascot of wall street
oligarchs
and a black puppet of corporate
plutocrats
obama has his memoir right now you just
mentioned it
have you reassessed your view of him
given what came after him
doesn't four years of trump's impact uh
does that change the way we see obama's
legacy
well i mean i've always thought that
brother barack was a brilliant brother
he's the highly poised brother
sister michelle is magnificent the two
wonderful wonderful daughters too
but my assessment of brother barack is
even worse now
when i look at the book because he tries
to engage in rationalization
of his captivity to wall street greed
the rationalizations
the pentagon militarism where is the
wrestling with
assassinating american citizen
with that killer list every tuesday with
no
due process he said if a republican did
that
new york times would go away barack does
it nobody wants to say a word where's
the moral consistency
famous with drones i thought he was
going to say something about how he felt
as if he could come to terms with rome
bush 45 drones war crime barack
obama 563 jones three
three jones war crime i call him i'm
just being consistent i said same thing
in my bush i say about him i'll say the
same thing about trump
even worse will say the same thing about
biden it's a matter of being morally
spiritually consistent here
and so the book actually reveals uh even
more uh a confirmation and even almost
vindication of what so many of us were
trying to say and i'm not the only one
as you know adolf breed has been saying
this and
and brother matt diaby and chris hedges
and naomi klein and chomsky
and yeah paul street i mean i'm not the
only one
let me ask you this things obama was so
worried about
you indeed what let me ask you this one
one of the things
one of the things obama was so worried
about and what biden has been so
concerned about this year
was being tagged as a socialist the
dreaded
s-word you're a proud democratic
socialist why do you think so many
americans
recoil from that word you even had house
democrats blaming socialism
for down ballot losses this year in
places like florida
i mean there is a uh association of
socialism
with the soviet union association of
socialism with repression
and and regimentation so i you
understand
that kind of misunderstanding it's sad
that that
is still often something that's taken
place but the kind of democratic
socialism i'm talking about was
the ways in which helen keller was a
democratic socialist the way in which
john dewey was a democratic socialist
the waiting was reinhold niebuhr was a
democratic socialist ways in which
martin luther king jr
was a democratic socials that has
nothing to do with soviet union
has nothing to do with repression
nothing to do with regimentation but in
the minds of most people when they say
social
and for me it's not really about an ism
just like i was telling brother
that as a christian i'm just trying to
bear witness to a truth and justice that
has to do with the least of these the
poor
the persecuted has to do with the genius
of hebrew scripture
that's spreading of hesset that loving
kindness to the orphan and widow and
fatherless and motherless
and that includes structures see the
jesus that i follow went straight
into the temple and ran out the money
changers
but what was the temple of that day was
a huge place it was
hollywood harvard
white house pentagon
at where the temple was to run out the
money changes those who had idols
that overlooked the humanity of the
wheat and the vulnerable
that's why jesus was crucified because
he ran the money changes
out of the temple so that's wall street
that's white house that's pentagon
that's hollywood that's harvard that's
yale even a little oxford brother
even christ church oxford where too many
of the elites are shaped
and mode and don't have enough in don't
have enough
concern with someone but
we're almost out of time we're almost
out of time i've got to ask you an
important question for a long time
you've been a lifelong opponent of
racism of white supremacy
uh we saw the black lives matter
movement go mainstream in america this
year majority support from the public
for the first time but what happens now
to black lives matter will a president
biden like a president obama make people
think
racism and police brutality is a thing
of the past how do you keep people
energized
keep people energized by connected to
the best that's what san kopha is and
what is connected to the best
martin luther king jr who said you got
to always highlight four issues
poverty militarism
racism and materialism and thinking you
can possess your soul by means of
possessing commodities so that when we
talk about black lives matter it's
always in the context
of the struggle against poverty to
struggle against
all forms of xenophobic not just racism
but
sexism not just sexism with homophobia
transphobia anti-jewish idiotic
anti-palestinian
and then always connected to some
alternative
to a system obsessed with
profit making at any cost that produces
a culture in which people think
they can do anything to the weak at any
cost and that includes on the global
scale
that includes nations right across the
board it could be ethiopia could be
israel
they think they can do something and get
away with it without any moral standards
without any spiritual standards
we have got to bear witness through
voice
to move
well said i think we're going to leave
it there on that very uplifting
inspirational note dr cornell west
thank you so much for your time you're
always welcome back on the show we
appreciate you